de longues files d'attentes devant les
magasins de tissus c'était fin avril et
les clients étaient tous là pour acheter
la même chose d'élastiques du tissu
faire des masques que j'en ai aucun
et pour faire des masques il faut une
machine à coudre qui marche comme celle
que vient de récupérer cette cliente
après un petit passage en réparation
quand même une erreur tout bête j'ai
fait tomber une quête pour resserrer une
vis à l'intérieur pour ma part très bon
ça n'est pas le cas de toutes celles là
pour répondre à la demande catherine
kiev et qui vend et répare des machines
depuis 40 ans a même dû ouvrir ces
ateliers deux jours par semaine pour que
les clients ne passent pas tous par ses
magasins débordée l'afflux vient du fait
que beaucoup de gens se sont remis à la
couture avec des machines qui était
peut-être un petit peu anciennes et qui
n'avait jamais été entretenues et la
couture des masques et en quelque chose
de relativement difficile beaucoup de
machines non pas du tout du tout du tout
apprécié donc c'est pour ça les gens
arrivent avec des machines qui avait pas
été révisée qui ont besoin de nos
services dans l'atelier de frédéric
duclos il y a de quoi faire aussi les
machines s'accumulent depuis deux mois
comme tous les réparateurs il croule
sous les demandes
on essaye de travailler dans l'urgence
voilà là j'ai une centaine de machines
c'est tout bonnement pas possible de
donner des délais donc on fait des
heures on tape dedans comme on dit
vulgairement et puis normalement ça sort
quoi donc j'ai pas vraiment des laîches
travail à la semaine c'est à dire qu'au
bourg une semaine principalement tout le
monde arrive à récupérer sa machine
cette couturière n'aura pas eu à
attendre aussi longtemps que juste une
petite révision de quelques minutes
ça n'est pas toujours aussi simple non
c'est moi qui vous remercie
vas-y monsieur on dit